un plan historique face à une situation
historique
tels sont les mots d' emmanuel macron
concernant la relance du secteur
automobile une filière en crise depuis
plusieurs années en france et qui est
particulièrement impacté par la pandémie
à ce jour plus de 400 mille véhicules
invendus sont stockées chez les
concessionnaires c'est depuis une usine
valeo à étaples
dans le pas de calais que le chef de
l'état a choisi d'annoncer son plan de
relance
il s'agit d'un plan de défense de notre
emploi industriel qui va être confronté
à l'une des plus graves crises de son
histoire
il s'agit d'un plan de souveraineté
industrielle automobile qui a vocation à
relocaliser de la valeur ajoutée et à
nous battre pour que la valeur ajoutée
les secteurs d'avenir se fasse en france
et il s'agit donc bien d'un plan
d'avenir de l'automobile du 21e siècle
ce plan de 8 milliards d'euros repose
sur trois axes soutenir l'achat
continuer d'investir afin de produire
les véhicules de demain en france est
scellé un pacte entre l'état les
entreprises et l'ensemble des salariés
du secteur pour relancer les ventes
l'exécutif s'engage dès le 1er juin
prochain à verser une prime à la
conversion exceptionnel celle ci sera
valable pour les deux cent mille
premiers véhicules achetés
autre déclaration du président le prêt
de 5 milliards d'euros garanti par
l'état sera accordé à l'entreprise
renault à condition d'obtenir certains
engagements sur l'avenir des salariés de
maubeuge et de doux et une annonce qui
n'a pas manqué de faire réagir la classe
politique
vous avez bien compris après avoir
arrosé les entreprises de 20 milliards
d'argent public sans aucune contrepartie
l'état s'apprête à garantir 5 milliards
à renault mais n'exigera rien s'agissant
des fermetures de sites envisagés
le grand plan pour l'automobile se
résume à un plan de sauvetage de renault
en difficulté depuis bien longtemps
pour le reste aucune relocalisation en
vue aucun frein aux fermetures annoncées
lors de son discours le chef de l'état a
notamment insisté sur sa volonté de
réconcilier deux secteurs l'économie et
l'écologie des ambitions en lien direct
avec le plan de relance européen initié
la semaine dernière en compagnie
d'angela merkel une proposition
franco-allemande qui entend notamment de
un coup d'accélérateur à la transition
écologique